if you look at a thermal image of a city
and then compare that to a map of
vegetation you'll find that where
there's greenery
the temperature is lower
that's because things like asphalt
concrete and shingled roofs
absorb more heat from the sun than trees
this is the urban heat island effect and
it accounts for higher temperatures in
cities
often by several degrees compared with
their surroundings
it's becoming a huge risk to human
health as growing urban populations
exacerbate the heating effects of
climate change
heat waves kill more people than any
other extreme weather event
more than tornadoes hurricanes and even
floods
that's why urban heat island mitigation
strategies
are being studied in singapore by a
group of researchers
the government-backed project called
cooling singapore
is now in the process of combining
everything they've learned
to create a digital tool that can help
cities all over the world
starting with singapore
[Music]
in singapore close to the equator
temperatures regularly rise above 32
degrees celsius
or 90 degrees fahrenheit and the city
structures only make it worse
and that is also the case for singapore
which is basically a concrete jungle
more urbanized more developed city and
even in singapore what you have
is a situation whereby there's a
temperature difference of seven degrees
celsius
between the more urbanized and the more
rural areas
the government has taken drastic steps
to keep temperatures down
this is gardens by the bay an
award-winning park
and inside this greenhouse is a pleasant
24 degrees
that's because the dome along with two
dozen nearby towers full of thousands of
people
is chilled by what's probably the
world's largest underground district
cooling system
it uses a large central plant that cools
water and then pipes it into banks
residential towers an exhibition center
shopping malls
and the city's iconic marina bay sands
hotel and casino complex
so one of the biggest perks of using
this system
for the buildings is that they can save
40
in terms of electricity usage compared
to your traditional air conditioners
and with singapore relying on natural
gas for most of its power this new
system means emission savings equivalent
to removing 10 000 cars from the city's
roads
that has big implications for the rest
of the world if things stay as they are
more than a third of the world's
electricity could end up being used to
cool buildings and vehicles by 2050
as the world gets hotter gets warmer
there is a greater need for air
conditioning and as well as
refrigerators for instance and the more
people are buying these
household appliances the more energy
usage they
they they use and they release heat more
and that then excessive bits climate
change
it's a vicious circle and so since 2017
researchers at cooling singapore have
been identifying design solutions
that reduce our need for so much cool
air in the first place
one thing many cities have in common and
as the importance of vegetation
that's a very important measure to
mitigate the urban heat
because of the shading effect of course
and deep psychological effects
of the vegetation and also because of
the
possible evaporative cooling effect of
the vegetation
vegetation can be of course on the
ground floor in form of trees and shrubs
and you can walk under them this is the
so-called canopy layer
that the vegetation forms above us but
vegetation can also go up the facades of
buildings
and it can go to the roof of the
buildings
luckily singapore has been striving for
the garden city feel for quite some time
it was a vision initially introduced by
then prime minister lee kuan yew in 1967
to make life more pleasant for people
and today singapore is one of the
world's greenest cities in terms of
urban vegetation
kampung admiralty a community centre
that contains health facilities and
social spaces
now provides more green space than the
plot of land it was originally built on
it's topped by a roof scape of staggered
terraces covered in local plants
which functions as a community park and
a village green in the center that
contains farm plots for residents to
tend to
park royal on pickering was designed as
a hotel in a garden
that doubled the green growing potential
of its site
there's now 15 000 metres of sky gardens
reflecting pools
waterfalls planted terraces and green
walls
and the government has big plans as well
singapore actually has a plan to plant
one million trees and add more green
spaces
over the next 10 years it is actually a
mix of
one thing to reduce the urban heat
island effect
but on the other hand is also to get the
people to be more connected to nature
but it's not enough the city-state has
still been warming twice as quickly as
the world average over the past six
decades
that's why cooling singapore has
developed a catalogue of other potential
heat mitigation measures
when you try to mitigate your heat iron
effect
in a city or in any building in a
village as well
the first place to start is by shading
off the windows you have to keep areas
clear so that the wind can move through
it
water of a certain depth can act as a
very good
thermal buffer if you have to construct
heavy buildings such as high rises
at least you can make the surface the
facade
less heavy and you can protect it from
direct sun
penetration we have to make sure that no
combustion engines
will be in the city in the middle in the
medium to
long-term range so ideally the
electricity production is
outside of the city and you bring just
the clean
electricity into the city you can at
least minimize the
use of energy in the city and you can
start
to slowly convert the roofs the facades
of the city into production areas for
renewable energy in singapore
unfortunately
this is a limited option but in the long
run it could produce
up to 20 25 of the energy of the
electricity needed
in singapore if all the roofs and the
areas in the buildings
on the buildings on the facades would be
used to do that
with so many different ideas cooling
singapore is also designing a virtual
model of the city to test them out
it's called a digital urban climate twin
or duct
that will calculate how each element of
the city's design
will impact the urban heat island effect
that means we model not only the
geometry of the buildings
digitally but also we model the
transportation
the insulation the temperature the
radiation coming from the sun
the weather the local weather the local
climate
the even very very microclimate of the
city
the water the movement of people in the
city
we can invent scenarios we can design
scenarios
test them before we actually build them
and if they test
very well and we are sure that they will
function then
we can start to build them and put them
into reality
singapore will be using this new tool to
figure out which actions it should take
next
and the model can be applied to any city
whether it needs to keep heat out
or keep heat in which will ultimately
save energy
slow climate change and improve our
quality of life
so this is something that singapore will
be able to export
maybe even together with its city
development
systems that it already has
singapore is one of the very few cities
in the world that really
combine this scientific approach with a
very
well established urban redesign and
design approach through its agencies and
the combination of its agencies
it has achieved a lot in the past
if it keeps following the scientific
path and the combination
with the other knowledge in the city
already
we think that it will be a very
comfortable
and very livable city in the future
even more than today
you